okay i'm here to tell you that a fox
news propagandist was right about
something but i am not telling you this
to suggest
that this is a good person overall i'm
merely telling you every once in a while
the right does something so depraved
that even the worst of the worst
right-wing clown
propagandists say this is too much for
me and it's a bad idea
and i'm talking about fox news host sean
hannity sean hannity came out against
the outrageous
armed protesters who have been showing
up with long guns
and handguns demanding states open
businesses and stop the coronavirus
public health measures
that actual doctors and public health
officials have determined are necessary
let's take a look at the clip from
hannity's program down policies
michigan i don't like this part in
michigan i'm the number one supporter in
radio and
television that i know of first
amendment and the second amendment
now no one is a bigger defender of the
second amendment than yours truly
everyone has the right to protest
protect themselves
and try to get the country open this
with the militia look here and these
long guns
uh no show of force is dangerous that
puts our police at risk
and by the way your message will never
be heard whoever you people are
no one should be attempting to
intimidate officials with a show of
force and god forbid something that
happens
then they're going to go after all of us
law abiding second amendment people i've
been carrying a
i have a carry permit my whole life all
right so he's right i mean these armed
protesters
are outrageous and it's dangerous and
it's a bad idea
and hannity has sort of stumbled across
the right position
the way a drunken guy at a bar sometimes
stumbles back to their car before
driving drunk and crashing the vehicle
hannity also has personal reasons like
he doesn't want the focus
being on his guns which he thinks it
might be
if these nuts keep showing up with
rifles to state capitals around the
country and actor john cusack actually
made a similar analogy
he tweeted quote nah not interesting
like a blackout drunk slurring an
apology after he crashed into innocent
people
he's a deranged pathological liar
enabler for a death cult
nothing he says has any adult human
value now the i generally agree but
i think that there is some value here
one reason that this is more than just
a broken clock being right once or twice
a day
is we know hannity has a huge real world
influence on his audience a couple weeks
ago we found
a we saw a study that found that
people who watch hannity as a primary
news source over
tucker carlson and other fox news hosts
the hannity watchers
are more likely to have gotten
coronavirus
realistically because hannity was more
against the lockdowns and downplayed the
seriousness of the virus
earlier on his viewers saw that
and were encouraged to participate in
riskier behavior
which made them more likely to catch the
virus so this actually does affect
people and the point is that
this is something when you think about
the role that sean hannity has for his
audience he's seen
as like a demigod by many of his viewers
and if he says the armed protesters
don't make sense this is too much
it doesn't make him a good person
doesn't make him right about anything
else that he said
but it actually might mean someone one
of his viewers
decides not to show up with a long gun
and we're all better off for it we're
all better off in every sense
but let me step back for a second i'm
going to be perfectly frank with you
here
i actually share sean hannity's
frustration
with the protesters uh but i also share
the frustration
of the protesters i don't own guns
i'm not showing up to protest and i
don't think that the governors
are the people we should be protesting
but i am outraged and frustrated and
saddened
that what we've been doing hasn't worked
because there's been no proper federal
coordination
of a functional national plan to deal
with the virus
so i'm with the protesters in that i
believe
what we've done has been worse for the
economy than it had to be
but we don't want to blame the governors
for that we need to be blaming donald
trump's administration
the process should have been on day one
of a confirmed
case that was january 20 the trump
administration should have immediately
developed a working test
like south korea did it wouldn't be
reasonable to expect
that trump would shut things down when
we had like 15
cases but remember that march 5th
we already had 221 cases in the united
states
on march 5th trump should have come out
and said
let's do a coordinated 50 state
shutdown what we saw then happening in
china remember march 5
china had 80 000 cases and we had 200.
that should have been enough when you
look at italy on march 5th
italy already had 4 000 cases
on march 5th so we knew how quickly it
could spread
in other countries as well if on march 5
trump had said we're shutting it down
i need all 50 governors to do this with
me we're going to do this for
you know we wouldn't have known at the
time how long but today is may 5th
right we would be 60 days in to a
federally coordinated shutdown the
spread would have been cut dramatically
we wouldn't now have new york and
massachusetts going down
while georgia florida and texas are
exploding right
we could actually have coordinated this
from the top
and really be looking at reopening now
instead we're in a situation
where cdc and fema believe we might be
at 3 000 deaths a day by
june 1st italy's cases are way down
spain's cases are way down frances are
way down south korea
you know they've managed to keep this to
a couple of hundred deaths total
and we still have one to two thousand
deaths a day and states are opening
prematurely and cases are spiking so my
point
is this if you want me to join the
protesters in
saying this was mishandled this didn't
need to be this
bad for the economy i'm right there with
you but protesting governors with guns
is not the right answer the right answer
is
hold the people accountable who did the
wrong thing the federal coordination
failed us those who uh should be held
accountable are in washington dc
and of course there are governors also
acting irresponsibly by wildly opening
up or never closing
let's hold them accountable now and
let's hold them accountable in november
as well
one of our sponsors today is a game
called law givers
a turn-based political simulation game
for pc
ios and android if you've ever wanted to
start a political party or run for
office or shape the destiny of our
country
here's your chance i've been having a
ton of fun with the game you do get to
experience
legislative democracy up close and the
dynamics of the game are really
impressive
you make election promises to your
constituents it's up to you whether you
keep those promises when you're in
office
all of the laws you pass affect your
country's happiness and safety
healthcare environment
you can abolish laws that are already in
place you can ratify the constitution
you decide if you want the government to
be a healthy democracy
or authoritarian tyranny you can be
corrupt and take bribes political
assassinations are part of the game it's
nuts actually
it's a really good time it doesn't get
old because you'll never play it the
same way twice
this is not some cheesy free-to-play
game
it's very clear that a lot of time went
into the development
it has very positive reviews on steam
and in the app stores four and a half
stars or higher on all platforms
go to davidpakman.com game which is
where you can watch the trailer
download the game for steam ios
and android that's davidpakman.com
game